uh welcome to session two of
understanding anger 2.0 I'm very happy
to have all of you here and we'll be
looking at platonic uh discussions and
texts that have to do with the
complicated emotion of anger in this so
if you're new to being in this class
this is looking at discussions of anger
in a variety of different genres so
philosophy literature also including
poetry drama and novels we'll be getting
to some Greek poetry later on in the in
the year religious thought not so much
this year but perhaps next year and even
some early medical thought as well that
has to do with anger you notice that I'm
the only person on camera at this point
that's because we're recording this so
other people people can participate in
it later on but we'll we'll go on camera
towards the end of the event right now
you can communicate through the chat and
afterwards once we get through all this
material we'll open up video and Mike
for those who are participating here now
this is our first session on Plato's
dialogues and if you've read much Plato
you might know that you know there's a
let's call it semi
systematic discussion of something
that's like anger encompassing anger
often a synonym for anger that we call
thumos in the Republic book four and in
a few other places connected with the
tripartite soul we're really not going
to be talking about that psychology here
we're going to do that a lot more in the
next session but it's worth you know
realizing that that's in the background
and that the platonic tradition isn't
just Plato it's going to influence all
these other thinkers that we call
platonists whether middle platonists or
neoplatonists and it's going to trickle
into a lot of
um Christian Greek thought in the early
era of Christianity where they are using
Plato's psychology quite a bit
so we're going to be looking at that a
bit more next session this session we
are going to be looking at depictions of
and discussions of anger primarily in
the texts that you could say are most
Central to this like the apology the
eutherfro uh the protagoras the gorgeous
and Republic book one and other bits of
the Republic
as well and Plato doesn't work out a
systematic theory of anger that's
articulated just in one text as a matter
of fact we're not going to see anything
well in surviving literature like that
until we get to people much later on
like plutarchs on anger a stoic text or
rather uh seneca's on anger uh which is
the stock text plutarchs on controlling
anger which is a middle platinous text
and and a few others as well but but
Plato's going to be mentioning anger
quite a bit in ways that I think can be
very useful for us understanding that
emotion in our own time in the present
you're going to see a lot of interesting
applications that hopefully we can get
some good discussion going about
um and so you know we don't want to
expect that we're going to get a
systematic you know once and for all
platonic answer instead we've got to
kind of work out a composite and see how
we can fit these parts together and
we'll get you know sort of an incomplete
answer about what's going on in Plato's
text so first where is anger mentioned
in terms of of someone getting angry we
want to be really careful as readers not
to just
think that because of the way people are
talking to each other for example in the
gorgeous which to many probably seems a
very anger-filled dialogue the way these
people are talking or Republic book one
we don't want to just assume that people
are motivated by anger it could also be
a kind of contentiousness a desire to
win that the Greeks called filonica
desire to conquer to have Victory could
be aggressiveness on their part that
could just be kind of gruff people they
could be contemptuous of their
interlocutors they could be what we
might call a hubris stick person
somebody who naturally
tends to to wound others in in the ways
that they behave and so what we want to
do is look for references or mentions of
what we can call it anger vocabulary so
anger in ancient Greek there's two terms
that we typically associate it with it
one is through most which like I
mentioned we'll talk a lot more about in
the next class session devoted to The
Republic and phaedris and Timaeus and
places like that the other is Oregon and
Oregon
um means like the the emotion The
Passion of anger thumos is a little bit
broader typically but sometimes used
synonymously with it as we mentioned in
the last class there's all sorts of
other vocabulary that gets used as well
you know the Iliad begins with a word
that doesn't get mentioned all that much
menus right there's all sorts of other
uh nouns and verbs so on ignoctane gets
used quite a bit in plain know sodas um
which comes from the word khada post
which means difficult but in in used as
a verb it means something like to to get
upset to get angry to start you know
getting aggressive with other people
um there's also miss Thai which has a
sense of being angry and there's other
words as well so what we'd want to do is
you know when we're looking at the Greek
texts if we can do that we want to see
whether these words are being used
whether people are being said to be
angry or whether it's something else
that's going on and it also a prime
example of this is Socrates old accusers
in the apology we're going to talk about
them quite a bit
um in the Youth of row he mentions his
fellow Athenians this is right before
the apology right we have anitus in the
Mino showing up he's one of Socrates
younger accusers and he gets pissed off
at Socrates and starts threatening him
we have of course through simicus early
on in the Republic and we have another
mention of another guy getting angry in
the Republic a story that's being told
now interestingly we also have a case
where
it's often translated with calacles uh
telling Socrates don't get angry at me
man don't get upset with me and we're
going to look at that a little bit more
more closely is it really anger is it is
it not
um in one of the most angry dialogue so
we're going to look at those shortly and
it's worth mentioning that anger does
come up in a few other dialogues so this
guy credius and the karmedies gets angry
uh kasapis gets angry in the udemius uh
in the lysius the tutors who are
supposed to be watching over the young
men they're drunk they get angry as well
and there's other there's other people
uh who are coming up now we can also ask
where are we getting discussions of
causes for anger and this is where we
start to get to the stuff that's more
more useful and perhaps more interesting
right so we know that some people are
more inclined fine to anger or other
Associated drives like striving after
honors wanting to win right being
aggressive uh contentiousness being
ready to fight other people and again
we're going to discuss that more in the
next session when we get to talking
about thumos and the tripartite soul
but we can also say that there are some
situations that are liable to make a
person more vulnerable to anger one of
the texts we're not really going to look
at here but is worth a mention and I
think we can probably all relate to to
some degree or you know we can remember
other people who behave this way when a
person is motivated by love or erotic
desire Eros then love makes them
quarrelsome and not just with everybody
else also with their lover or beloved
right and so that makes them more liable
to to anger but we can think of all
sorts of other things that get people
angry Snickers made a great set of
commercials about being hangry a while
back you know if somebody would be
saying mean things you know like
somebody would say they're a model
they'd be like yeah a hand model and
then you know they get a Snickers bar
and they eat it now they're not so so
upset anymore right so that's that's
kind of a an interesting uh idea and you
know in general this is a theme that's
going to come up over and over and over
again in all of the literature that
we're looking at people tend to get
angry when they think that they
themselves or people or things that they
value are being wronged or insulted or
treating bad treated badly or unfairly
and Plato mentions this at certain
points but I think he just kind of
assumes it in the background a lot of
the time he's not going to thematize it
quite so much as later thinkers will
um
there are however in the text that we're
going to look at some really really
interesting and I think useful
discussions that we can piece together
about people getting angry in the course
of discussing matters with other people
so this is where the real payoff I think
for this session is going to lie in
looking at these texts like the youth
referral and the gorgeous the protagoras
and and a few others and deriving what
we might call
um a non-systematic but General set of
guidelines about you know why it is that
people do get upset with each other in
discussions there's also another thing
that we're going to talk about which is
people getting angry with other people
over their character flaws or their bad
decisions and commitments and the word
thumos is in fact used there now it's
put in the mouth of protagoras rather
than Socrates or you know the Athenian
stranger or anybody like that so I think
we have to be a little bit careful uh
about saying that that's Plato's own
point of view but there's uh there's
something worth thinking about and
hashing out there
so um before we jump into looking at
these texts let's do a little bit more
ground preparing what can we actually
say about Plato's views on this emotion
of anger
so as I mentioned there's no systematic
treatment of anger or thumos in Plato's
dialogues outside of this framework we
could say of the the tripartite soul
that we're getting in the Republic
supplemented by the Timaeus and by the
um phaedrus which we're going to look at
next time
but anger is definitely something of
concern to Plato right so we see that
characters within dialogues are
concerned worried
um trying to prevent Anger from taking
place as well as getting angry
themselves and why well because you know
by Plato's time they realize that anger
can lead to being out of control to
making morally bad decisions or foolish
decisions getting yourself into conflict
that's unnecessary you know Plato is
writing against the background of you
know an entire culture that's been
thinking about anger in you know
non-systematic ways but depicting it in
the case of people like you know
Achilles
um for Generation after generation after
generation so there's that background
there
we can also say that anger sure
along with other problematic or
disruptive emotions you know the Greeks
were particularly worried about Envy
Sonos but you know we could also talk
about fear excessive desire this this
desire to always be right or to conquer
other people these can lead to all sorts
of issues within relationships
within a household within the larger
society and we could say within the
world in in general so Plato is
interested in and concerned with anger
but he's not going to single it out so
much as something you know to write a a
particular dialogue you notice there's
no Dialogue on anger or even on the The
Virtue that's often associated with
managing your anger proudes right this
calmness or gentleness
um
and we can ask with Plato as with other
authors well why do you think it's
important that we understand anger and
Plato's answer would be a bit different
than some of the later authors that
we're going to be looking at I think
that Plato's answer would be something
like well so we can use anger rightly
and productively for you know the proper
purposes that we have it for and avoid
falling into it when it's not helpful
and you know making mistakes because of
that so this is not uh Aristotle's
answer Aristotle's answer would include
something like well the person you know
the rhetor or the psychologist needs to
know how to awaken anger in people or to
mute it how anger actually works you
need to have a more or less scientific
understanding of this emotion Arizona
also says you know that somebody who's
interested in biology or physiology
would be interested in Anger for other
reasons and would have a different
viewpoint on it and then we could talk
about you know the ethical stuff
um the stoics coming later would say we
need to understand anger because anger
is inherently bad and we must root it
out and here's all the techniques to do
that
um that's not Plato's point of view
Plato doesn't think that anger is
intrinsically or inherently bad as a
matter of fact
um not only can it be not bad in some
cases it's actually quite good and even
needed
um so you know
telling when those cases are that's the
that's the tricky part so let's look at
the instances in Plato's dialogues where
people get angry and then maybe we'll do
a little bit of q a and discussion and
then move on to
the lessons that we can draw about how
does anger actually work
so notice again that we can make a
mistake and read anger into the platonic
texts where we can't really be sure that
it's it's there we attribute it to
characters when there isn't any mention
of it in the text and I think this is a
bit of a digression but I think this is
very analogous to how people today read
anger in to all sorts of other people's
discourse Behavior attitudes uh actions
when we can't be sure that it's actually
there so you know for example in online
discourse this happens all the time you
know I may have somebody
um say something that's a little bit
bone-headed and you know a little bit
full of themselves as a YouTube comment
and then I'll respond well no you've got
Plato wrong there you probably want to
go and you know read the texts rather
than just opine about this since you're
off base and they'll be like why are you
getting angry with me bro and you know
I'll be like well that's a weird thing
to assume if I'm not actually if I was
writing in all caps or something okay
that stands for being angry right or
emphatic
um
but there's no necessity to read anger
in where it doesn't exist I think that a
lot of this is people projecting their
own lack of emotional intelligence or
you know their own problems with anger
on to everybody else they assume well if
you're correcting me you must be doing
it out of anger because that's the way I
behave right and I think this is very
common with many other things we could
talk about fear we could talk about uh
desire we could talk about all sorts of
other emotions so I'm not I'm not
singling that out but we don't want to
do that with Plato's texts we want to be
careful as readers so we're not
injecting something that isn't actually
there just because we happen to
interpret it that way so what do we have
well I think we can break it down into
three interesting sets of stuff so
there's the whole drama of Socrates
being put on trial
um because of the activities that he
engages in philosophical activities in
Athens with his fellow citizens you may
remember from the apology that he talks
about having older accusers and younger
accusers so in the amino as I've
mentioned already
we have one of the younger accusers show
up his name is anatus and along with
malayitus and and lycon and a few others
he is bringing the charges against
Socrates for corrupting the young and
impiety and we get to see that anatus
himself is an angry guy he shows up in
the middle of this dialogue between
Socrates and Mino that you know if you
haven't read you should you should check
it out it's worth worth checking out and
he comes in right at the end when
they're discussing whether any of the
great men of Athens are able to teach
virtue to their their kids and the
evidence that they don't really
understand virtue that they've just been
kind of Lucky had right opinion is that
they're you know Pericles his kids turn
out bad and we see this not just with
you know previous examples but
contemporary examples
anitus is is convinced that any good guy
in Athens can teach virtue Socrates
um you know shows that there's good
reasons for us not to think that's the
case and anatis then says as he's
angrily leaving you better watch it
Socrates that sort of thing is going to
get you in trouble so he's threatening
retaliation right and he's saying other
people are going to get angry at you the
way that I am and that's indeed what
we're going to find right
um in the Youth of fro which comes right
before the apology Socrates says that
he's fine with people laughing at him
now this is going to come up in other
places as well but he's really concerned
about the Athenians becoming angry with
him and the word there is thumontai
having thumos having anger directed at
him and he says I don't know how things
are going to turn out in this case of
mine now he goes in in the apology and
he gives a speech that you you could say
um and we don't actually have you know
some textual evidence for this but you
could say boy that speech seemed really
set up well to piss people off you know
he begins by saying I'm not going to be
like the rest of you Schmucks and bring
my kids in here to cry and stuff like
that I'm just gonna present the facts
you know I'm not going to talk in a
normal like law school legal Court kind
of way I'm just going to talk the way
I'm used to talking and then you know
there's other points where he's kind of
zinging the audience right where for
example he is uh convicted and now
they're deciding what his penalty ought
to be and He suggests to them you know I
do so much good for you that you should
give me free meals for the rest of my
life so he's he's to some degree it
looks like he's antagonizing the
audience
now he comes in and you all remember he
gives this speech where he says I've got
younger accusers he'll actually
cross-examine one of them and make him
look like a fool and I've got these
older accusers and these older accusers
are the ones who I really have to fear
because they've been saying things to
you that are untrue about me for years
and years and years so you the jury are
prejudiced against me and I don't know
how much of a defense I can make but I
can at least tell you how things
happened and well what is how things
happen he tells this crazy story about
you know he's on a mission from God and
and uh I won't go into all the details
but the mission from God consists in
going around and questioning people who
are supposed to be wise so you know he
goes after the politicians the political
leaders right or would-be leaders of the
state and when he asked some questions
about Justice and prudence and things
like that turns out they don't actually
know what it is that they claim that
they know and they get ticked off with
them they don't like that right and so
you know he uses this word
um
right uh to to denote that and then he
goes to the poets and he does the same
thing to them they don't actually know
what they're talking about you can see a
nice example of that in his uh dialogue
the ion where he's talking not to a poet
directly but to a interpreter of poetry
the rhapsod ion this really sweet guy
who doesn't get angry at Socrates but if
he was a different kind of you know rap
zoner poet maybe he would and then he
goes to the crafts people you know
doctors plumbers Carpenters shoemakers
pick whatever you want right and he
shows that they know one thing well but
they don't know the other stuff well and
they when they get outside of their
proverbial Lane they are ignorant and so
how do people respond when you show
quite publicly that they're ignorant
they don't like it
and so they get mad at him and then
they're more liable to believe these
lies that people like Aristophanes tell
in several different plays and other
people are saying about this Socrates
guy and so that's that's part of the
story there right
um in the ongoing drama we have The
Credo and interestingly in The Credo
Socrates introduces this this character
of the laws and the Commonwealth of
Athens right and they're going to talk
to him and he's he's saying Credo listen
to what they're saying here and the laws
tell him that
you're more bound to respect and and
placate that is you know uh reduce right
deal with your country's anger than your
father's anger implying that Socrates
country or his city-state Athens is
ticked off with him and he says if you
cannot persuade and placate it then you
have to abide by its judgments and
punishments namely your death sentence
and if you don't do that you're you're a
bad guy Socrates so with the city being
angry with you what you should have done
was actually mollify it rather than keep
poking at it and taking the kind of
stand that you did now we shouldn't be
too Keen in interpreting these to think
that we can really differentiate you
know thumos versus order gay versus you
know other kinds of anger I think we can
say that you know the Athenians in
general were angry angry at Socrates for
a long time in different ways that
ultimately led to his conviction and
execution or self-administered execution
in that case so that we've got that
going on right and then we've got angry
people in dialogues and who is the prime
example of an angry person in a platonic
dialogue that we know is angry because
Plato tells us well Socrates tells us
that he is through simicus this guy who
is involved in a discussion about
Justice and he can barely uh hold back
his temper and barely hold back his
impatience because he sees all these
dummies Socrates and you know adamantis
and uh you know glauca and all these
people Jibber jabbering about what
Justice is and not actually arriving at
any answer when through simicus knows
what it is and he will tell them and he
knows how valuable his knowledge is so
he expects a fee and he expects them to
sit down and shut the hell up and let
him talk right he's he's an angry guy
he's not just angry at that moment his
very way of talking is angry his
character is that of an angry person
and um you know this is actually
interestingly going to change a bit as
the dialogue goes on he's going to sulk
and then it's going to be mentioned
again I believe in Republic book six
that through simicus now has been calmed
and wants to hear more of what Socrates
has to say
we also have a funny story about this
guy uh leontius who gets angry with
himself this is in Republic book four uh
and he's angry at his own appetite and
in his own eyeballs because he wants to
look at Corpses
and he's like this is disgusting why am
I doing this I mean how many of us get
angry at ourselves for in engaging in
things that are time wasting or foolish
you know think about going down a rabbit
hole in YouTube or Wikipedia and being
like there's an hour of my life I'm
never going to get back what the hell's
wrong with me right so that that could
happen we also get this guy uh critius
in the karma days which we're not going
to really go into here but it's worth
you know mentioning a little bit he gets
angry
um because his idea gets refuted by
proxy you know Socrates is going after a
similar idea
um
gets angry in the youth edemus at the
suggestion he would like to see this
other person clinious get destroyed when
instead he wants cleaning us to learn so
it's sort of like saying hey you're not
a good friend you're not a good parent
you're not a good teacher you're not
taking care of the people that you
should be doing you're trying to wreck
them instead of educate them so he gets
mad at that not in the lysius as I
mentioned the tutors are drunk now
getting drunk you know kind of
predisposes you to getting angry as I
think many of us know from experience
and they get angry at the crowd for not
minding their own damn business and
interfering and then in the Fado there's
a very interesting mention there about
the gods getting angry with us why would
the gods get angry with us well if we
destroy ourselves if we take our own
lives we are possessions of the gods
that are damaging themselves and so the
gods would be rightly angry at us just
as if I were to be angry at my coffee
cup here for somehow wrecking itself
right so these are all examples so
that's a second class we got the
Socrates himself and now we've got other
angry people in dialogues and then we
get the third thing a curious case
so calicles
in the gorgeous will tell Socrates
not to be angry or upset with him he
says
right now
why is this so weird
well
um calacles has just been telling
Socrates that philosophy is for children
not for grown men like him he's just had
a long speech where he's like Socrates
this philosophy stuff it's really great
it's part of a good education but you're
not supposed to be sticking with this as
a mature adult let alone as an old guy
like you what what's wrong with you
you're childish you know you should have
abandoned that stuff and started paying
attention to the things that really
matter philosophy is an instrument sort
of like rhetoric which is the topic of
the uh the dialogue itself it's not the
thing that you're supposed to be
engaging in you're supposed to be you
know competing for honors you're
supposed to be taking care of yourself
and those who depend on you he's got a
legitimate complaint there by the way
and remember too that this is gorgeous's
own house right where Socrates butted in
and and has shown up two of his honored
guests gorgeous and polis gorgeous
student and he's made them look Well
gorgeous he he's he's sort of on an
equal uh footing with right policies
made look like an idiot and polis is
kind of ticked off you could imagine
that calacles would have reason to be
offended by Socrates own behavior but
he's telling Socrates don't get mad at
me for telling you this stuff
and Gord or calacles is going to claim
to have Good Will eonoia in Greek
towards Socrates I'm telling you this
stuff for your own good man and then
Socrates just a little bit later and I
think ironically there's a lot of irony
in this dialogue is going to credit
calocles with three important things
he says I can I can trust you in this
conversation why because you have
knowledge epistem eh
Goodwill unoia and frankness of speech
you'll tell me what's on your mind
you're not going to hold stuff back so
you're a straight shooter buddy I I can
trust you
the dialogue itself when you're reading
it and I'd be interested in hearing
people's Impressions who've read it
through it seems like a very angry
dialogue and it's a lot of commentators
have pointed this out but the word anger
doesn't actually come up
or the terms for anger don't actually
come up all that often in the dialogue
itself so let's take a little pause in
case anybody has any questions
comments and then we'll jump into the
the second part of
um the session and talk about causes of
anger how anger does in fact arise
according to Plato and what lessons we
can draw from that so if you have any
questions comments about all the stuff
that we've talked so far just leave them
in the chat and all right well I'm not
seeing any questions or comments so I'm
going to just assume that everything is
clear enough at this point you can ask
them later on and we'll go off uh
recording later on and we can chat about
it as well so let's talk about what
causes anger how does anger actually
arise and Plato is not going to go into
you know some really deep psychology
he's mostly looking at things in terms
of well what kind of Dynamics do we
observe
and this can be very helpful I think for
for us in many ways so I mentioned
before that anger often arises out of a
perception that somebody else is doing
something they shouldn't be doing right
they're doing something wrong or they're
treating somebody badly they're being
unjust unfair
um
this is mentioned in Plato's Republic
book four as one of the things that does
provoke anger right and this is
something that we're going to see lots
and lots of other thinkers take up as
well and I think that this is almost
like a common place why do people get
angry because they think that something
shouldn't have been done and it hurt
them hurt people they care about hurt
things that they care about and
um you know Plato's not going to flesh
this out quite so much as other thinkers
will but I think that's there in the
background so
in the phaedrus as I mentioned he
discusses the tendencies that lovers
have to take offense at the action or
the inaction of the lover or the Beloved
why does this happen I mean this is
something that I think we can say still
goes on today when we're in a close
relationship where we desire something
from the other person if they're not
giving it to us we feel like we're being
treated badly so you know I'm attracted
to this person they were attracted to me
they're no longer attracted to me now I
feel like crap I'm questioning my own
attractiveness or desirability and I
start getting mad at them right why why
did you change
um somebody says that they're going to
meet us for a date and they show up an
hour late and we actually like a bunch
of Schmucks sat around waiting for them
and they come in and then they're like
oops I got another date and I gotta go
oh that'll really make somebody mad
right so there's all sorts of things
along those lines and we can talk about
other
similar disappointments not just in the
world of love but maybe in the workplace
you know we've been told that we're a
valuable employee uh so important to the
organization and we're going to you know
get a promotion anytime soon and then we
see somebody else getting promoted we're
like what the hell what's going on here
I thought you said that I was re you
know you were going to promote me you
know well no no we we had other needs in
the company this happens all the time
right
so um
there's a lot of other instances I think
where we can read this in you know his
discussions about people getting angry
at uh being shown up we see this coming
up by the way in Republic book five
people he says people who possess mere
opinion rather than knowledge they get
angry with the people who are showing
them when this is revealed or
demonstrated this is exactly what
Socrates did as discussed in the apology
to his older accusers right so we can we
can read that in there and say yeah
they're they're angry over that sort of
thing I mean we see other dialogues
where people are seemingly getting upset
with Socrates for making them look
foolish or like they don't know what
they're talking about but we also see
dialogues where that doesn't happen
where it's quite interesting
um in the use of fro so now we're going
to start to get to some of the real meat
in the user fro there's a really
important discussion that takes place
and this is early on and I think that a
lot of people miss this because they're
too interested in getting right to the
euthyphro Dilemma you know which doesn't
come up quite the way that people
interpreted it later on in the dialogue
itself and this is you could say one of
the lead-ups to the Youth of fro dilemma
so user fro had to find piety or
Holiness as what it is that the gods
love and impiety by contrast is what it
is that the gods hate
so then the question comes up do the
gods actually agree on what is lovable
and and hateful and it turns out that if
we look at Greek mythology
um clearly not I'll give you one prime
example which comes up in the Odyssey
um you know
Hephaestus the Smith God he's married to
Aphrodite he seems to think that
marriage and Fidelity are important
things right his wife Aphrodite
not quite so much goddess of love she
gets together with Aries his brother God
of War and they you know they have sex
enjoy themselves and have faced us now
is pretty ticked off about that and he
does you know creates this net you may
know the story and all that clearly
they're not all on the same page about
marriage adultery Fidelity these sort of
values right so they disagree about
about certain things
um
and so you know when we when we look at
that we can say what are the things that
we have disagreements about and the
answer is for us human beings and
presumably also for the gods all sorts
of things
now what agreements can we settle pretty
easily if people disagree about math
right let's say accounting how to figure
out what your costs are what your uh
cash flow is what you know who you need
to invoice how much for uh what you need
to do for your taxes that's you know
that can be a little complicated
sometimes but it's pretty
straightforward and if somebody wants to
argue with like really really basic
arithmetic like somebody wants to say I
think everyone else says that that two
plus three equals five I think it's six
you're like well you're nuts uh get the
hell out of here you don't have a role
in this discussion so it's not like
calculation or things like that that we
we get really upset with each other
about I mean people get mad and
frustrated when they can't figure out a
problem but that's a different issue
what kind of disagreements
uh what kind of diaphora do we have that
produces hatred and anger
so the gods and human beings differ and
they can't resolve their differences
easily about what we can call moral
qualities and this is something that
comes up over and over and over in the
platonic text these different let's call
them ranges of value
the just and the unjust the the Kaya and
the adika right
um that's one thing we could translate
that as the right and the wrong or the
you know following the rules and not
following the rules however we want to
parse out Justice and Injustice
the good and the bad as such the agathon
and the kakon right uh the noble and the
base or the beautiful and the uglier the
fine and the foul these these terms that
I'm throwing out there they all
translate the cologne and Ice sometimes
also honorable and dishonorable right so
now we've got three ranges of value and
we could also talk about other things
the pleasant and the unpleasant
um the useful and the harmful right
these are all modalities of value and
people and the gods disagree about what
these actually are and how to apply them
in specific cases and when they disagree
about these things they get angry with
each other and they can develop into
hatreds conflicts why why would this be
the case well
we find that there there might be an
assumption going on can you imagine how
screwed up somebody has to be to be
possibly saying that this is is okay
this is just you know and then you look
at it from the other person's point of
view and they're like oh well can you
imagine those jerks over there
condemning me for for defending this
thing over here that's just we do
disagree about these incredibly
important moral qualities and those
disagreements are places where anger
arises anger and hatred
in the gorgeous moving on
um there is this discussion that
Socrates has early on with this guy
gorgeous gorgeous has just been saying
that rhetoric can be used for good or
for bad it's not you know the fault of
the art or the teacher if somebody does
use it for for bad and Socrates then
says to gorgeous something kind of
interesting
he says that speakers often when they're
discussing something that they disagree
about they often can't define the topic
of the debate right it says epigerosene
the elegaste
right so
to put boundaries to Define right around
something and they're they're having
dialogue with each other they're not
just
talking Legacy they're having engagement
with each other and the epihero scene
um you know putting their hands to
deciding to uh engaging in in dialogue
so speakers often can't define the
topics that they're discussing and this
you know keeps them from being able to
teach and learn with each other he uses
the word moth on taste there learning
right being a student and dedoc santase
uh hayatus mutually teaching and
learning from each other which is what a
dialogue ideally would look like right
so what happens when this is the case
well we often attribute bad motives bad
um attitudes bad assumptions to the
other person we think that the other
person doesn't communicate rightly
orthos correctly or clearly Sophos in
this discussion that we're having in the
debate literally the office Betos so
scene right so taking different sides
the amphi is both right or putting two
things apart from each other
and so because they think the other
person isn't speaking rightly or clearly
they get angry right
jalapai nusi is the word that's being
used there they become difficult they
get angry they get bristly with each
other
and they think that the other person is
speaking with malice or jealousy even we
could say katathon uh towards them they
the other person is being unfair in in
the discussion in the debate and so
what's motivating the other person what
are they attributing to them they're
more aiming at winning they're motivated
by filonikia this desire to be right
this desire to Triumph This desire to
set oneself over other people uh to win
the contest they're more motivated by
that than they are at investigating the
matter that they're supposed to be
talking about so we could say they're
they're arguing in bad faith they're not
they're arguing with an agenda not the
agenda the right agenda of seeking out
the truth together and if one person is
you know thinking that they're being a
good uh argument partner and that the
other person is taking advantage of the
situation by trying to just win
they get angry they don't like that
understandably so right and I think we
can we can uh look back at our own
experience and say yeah this kind of uh
uh
this tracks doesn't it right
um maybe we've also been the person
who's striving to win and be right
rather than actually be in touch with
the truth at some times I know that's
certainly been the case for me and he
says you know this can often lead to all
sorts of shameful spectacles and abusive
language he uses this term uh loiter Ray
fentes loiteros is abuse right you know
calling people names uh saying all sorts
of bad stuff about them implying that
their motives are no good right and so
is this a dynamic that we do in fact see
now we've got two right the
euthyphrodynamic we can call it of
disagreement about what moral values are
and how they're applied disagreement
about how the uh discussion ought to go
and whether the person the other person
is arguing in good faith or not or
investigating in good faith and then we
have a third one which is coming from
the protagoras so this is put in the
words of protagoras
who is Socrates uh interlocutor in this
dialogue
and protagoras makes a claim that seems
to go against the euthyphro uh uh
Dynamic here
so he says that
um when a person makes a claim to a
skill like say flute playing if they
don't actually have that skill then we
now remember back to what we're saying
either earlier we either laugh them down
right so we we ridicule them we're like
ah look at this jackass here pretending
like he knows the flute he doesn't know
anything right or we get angry at them
the word there call a binus scene right
we we get irritated with them right we
make trouble for them
I'll just remind you so Socrates had
said that he would be cool with people
getting uh people laughing at him
finding him ridiculous it was people
getting angry with him that he's worried
about right so here we see these two
things coming up in a totally different
dialogue
um
protagoras claims that when it comes to
like justice and political wisdom and
virtue everybody's got a little bit of
this and we really want people to be
trained in this so when people come into
the assembly or the law courts or pick
wherever you want they're talking about
this sort of stuff we don't really get
angry at them
um we let anybody make whatever claims
they they want to right now that seems
to go against what we saw Socrates
actually getting euthyphro to to admit
in the euthyphro so that's probably
wrong that's probably wishful thinking
on protagoras's part if we think that
people are making claims or test skills
or knowledge that they don't actually
have could even be the stuff that we
don't understand right
we're going to get angry at them because
we think who the hell are you to be
talking about this taking up space you
know why are you putting yourself
forward as an authority when you don't
know a damn thing right we
say things like that so I think that
that is another interesting Dynamic
again we don't have like a great depth
of psychology coming from Plato on this
but we could like figure out what the
guiding assumptions might be and we have
these three Dynamics now all of which
pertain to interactions with other
people about things that we think matter
right uh moral values
um discussions of topics and seeking out
truth and then finally who's actually
got the credentials who's got the skills
who's got the knowledge or qualities
there is one other thing that comes up
in the protagoras that I do want to
bring up we could call this a fourth
Dynamic right
he says that we don't get angry at
people for faults that we think result
from nature foosis or chance just
Randomness right so you know what are
examples of that being ugly you know if
you're born ugly you're kind of stuck
with that this is before plastic surgery
right uh or being little you know being
too short or being weak having physical
ailments or stuff like that he says we
don't get angry at people
nobody would get angry with another
person over this now of course we could
say yeah but people do get angry over
that sort of thing all the time and
blame those people well sure there's a
protagoras talking
but protagoras says and I think this
this is something we can uh
say he's probably right about
when it comes to qualities good
qualities that we're supposed to develop
through care and practice and
instruction so I want to pause on those
words
um out of epimalea like paying attention
to things
out of practice
right out of training or discipline
and out of instruction the Das case
um you know learning teaching and
learning when it comes to these good
qualities that we're supposed to have
like you know for example Justice
um when people lack that
we get angry at them it says
[Music]
we we become angry people with them when
we realize that they are lacking it why
because it's their own damn fault we
think you know why did you turn out the
way that you did well
um maybe you didn't get the instruction
but you could have actually paid
attention to yourself epimlea right or
you could have done some practice
um and and we think that people are
responsible for the kind of people that
they've become
I think that this tracks again and I'd
be curious to see what everybody else
thinks about this as well so uh what
implications can we draw from what we've
been talking about here what we've
learned from Plato
um again we don't have a great depth
psychology being deployed here there's
no like scientific attitude towards it
as we're going to see an Aristotle but
we've identified now some very common uh
dynamics that have to do with why people
get angry with each other so that can
allow us to be on guard against each of
these Tendencies we can look at you know
when we start getting a little bit hot
in a discussion with somebody because we
disagree about what the noble or the
base or the just and the unjust are we
can be like ah
euthaphrodynamic maybe I don't need to
be so angry with these people about that
and we can anticipate other people's
anger arising as well
maybe we want to take on a kind of
Socratic attitude you notice that
Socrates doesn't get angry with his
interlocutors even when they're being
insulting towards him he doesn't resp he
doesn't Fight Fire with Fire he doesn't
clamp back as we say uh he will you know
get in his zingers and he will be ironic
with them which kind of ticks people off
as well but he has a different way of
approaching
um people you know and what does he do
he has a concern for truth so if we
think about the gorgeous
um Dynamic that we were discussing just
a minute ago that gorgeous Dynamic of uh
assuming you know the other person is
just trying to win uh not really
motivated by things Socrates
he doesn't do that his interlocutors
often say that to him but he's like nah
man let's let's find the truth in this
and as a matter of fact he wants to make
the person you see this in the gorgeous
his his talk with polis he wants to make
the person a witness for their own
position he's taking other people
seriously he wants to know what it is
that they actually have to say about
these things and the other thing that he
does that's that's pretty cool is he
um
you know attributes ignorance or
misguided opinion in place of deliberate
evil to most of the people that he's
talking to now maybe he goes too far
with that right you know Socrates has
this famous idea that nobody really does
evil willingly maybe he's wrong about
that right maybe a lot of people do the
wrong thing including engaging in these
Dynamics and getting angry at other
people and retaliating because of uh you
know mistaken opinions on their part or
ignorance of what the good actually is
so that's you know just some suggestions
I think we have to be careful with those
we shouldn't adopt those as like an
absolute blanket policy
another thing we can do and I'm kind of
you know I'm going to suggest this but I
don't actually completely endorse it
myself
would be to do what Socrates does with
calacles in the gorgeous and attribute
to people
good qualities like knowledge and
Goodwill unoia being properly disposed
to other people and frankness of speech
padresia
I'm I'm a bit conflicted about that
because I think a lot of people from a
platonic perspective don't actually have
knowledge
um Socrates is probably being a little
bit ironic in attributing knowledge to
calacles or really any of the
interlocutors in that dialogue The
Gorgeous
um but you know maybe we should give
people more of the benefit of the the
doubt
um at least at first right if they
display themselves as being ignorant
bigoted contentious okay maybe then you
know they don't have good will maybe
then they don't have knowledge maybe
they're not even being frank in speech
right
another thing that
um we could say is you know possible and
Socrates I think is a good example of
this in Republic book six
um
Socrates is going to say that
philosophers can model the opposite of
anger calmness
for non-philosophers in their
interactions with them so not only can
they
be you know less liable to stir stuff up
that can actually be a good role model
over time for how they ought to behave
and I'll close by mentioning that in
another later dialogue the sophist there
is mention of a person who is
dialectically questioned getting angry
and they get angry
about lacking knowledge but they get
angry not at the other person who's
showing that they lack knowledge they
get angry at themself for lacking that
knowledge which is kind of like the
protagoras thing that we noted just a
little bit earlier where we get angry at
those who didn't develop themselves
properly and are stupid or bigoted or
foolish or you know things they have
qualities that they should have done
themselves so in the sofas the person
who's being dialectically questioned
could be like oh man yeah I'm off base
it's me that's the problem and then you
you can get angry at yourself which
results according to Plato in being more
calm or gentle towards other people
realizing that you've got it wrong can
help you not be as angry again is this a
universal Maybe not maybe there has to
be a certain development of character in
order for that to to take place by I
think these are some some useful
implications that we can draw some
lessons from Plato So before we open
things up to q a
welcome to to June and Mark who who got
here a bit late I think in part because
not taking account of the fact that
America went on to Daylight Savings Time
uh you might be angry for missing part
of the discussion
um we're just actually close to the the
end of the session but uh so we've
talked about places in Plato's dialogues
where we see people getting angry where
anger is being mentioned we've talked
about these you know dynamics that we
can call out and use as lessons about
our own anger other people's anger maybe
used to some degree for some guidance
next session we're going to be going
deeper into Plato's ideas and we'll be
doing so by looking at Republic book
four also two and three where you know
like let's call it the Thematic person
is being discussed how do you keep them
from going bad right and will also uh be
looking at the Timaeus and the phaedrus
where this tripartite soul is discussed
and if we have the time we'll maybe look
at the laws as well so but we've got a
good start on Plano here so let's open
it up for any sort of questions comments
ideas that people have about that yeah
Mark and and June uh are uh
the time switch can be quite frustrating
right it's in international stuff it's
always uh going to be a bit weird
especially when we're talking about not
just uh America to Europe but also say
to the southern hemisphere South America
Africa uh Australia places like that
where people are coming on and off
daylight savings time this is actually
something that people can get quite
frustrated about as a matter of fact I'm
going to use this as as an example so
um you know we talked a little bit
earlier about
um what is it that people get get angry
about right and in the Youth of fro
mathematics and calculation are not
something people get angry about
daylight savings time can be very very
confusing we're springing forward
leaping back how does how's this working
you know what's going on with what time
zone
um I think people can get quite
frustrated when it comes to matters of
what seems to be simple mathematics when
it's tied to complex matters that we
can't quite wrap our heads around like
when you look at a spreadsheet and
you're like these numbers don't add up
what the hell's going on here is this
Creative Accounting as we call it right
so
um that's that's something well worth
thinking about all right so we got some
questions from Jamie do you think
there's a relation between knowledge and
anger in Plato's text and how does this
connect to Plato's theory of forms so
there's really no connection to Plato's
theory of forms and the connection to
knowledge you could say that
um
there's a couple different connections
to knowledge or to the to the lack of
knowledge so people get angry
when they think as we mentioned with the
protagoras people are claiming expertise
that they don't actually have
um they can be laughed at or they people
can get angry at them
um you know when people are revealed to
lack knowledge then they often get angry
as a response as well as we saw happens
with Socrates and is mentioned in uh the
Republic as well and so you know we get
angry at people who talk uh in ways that
we could say seem ignorant to us right
now we could be wrong about that right
like anatus getting angry at Socrates
when Socrates is saying listen all these
people that we think are virtuous
they don't actually understand virtue
they don't know what virtue is they have
that best right opinion and anatus is
like that's I'm angry now you
better watch out Socrates so you know
the connection between anger and
knowledge isn't uh that straightforward
and simple I I guess you could say that
um
people get angry over claims about who
actually has knowledge and who's seeking
knowledge So Jamie also says could you
say if everybody would have all the
knowledge people would no longer be
angry yeah trivially so I mean that's
never going to be the case
um so that I mean that's like a
hypothetical of a hypothetical of a
hypothetical Plato doesn't doesn't think
that'll ever be our our situation
um you could say that let's say we
restrict it to like the philosophers and
the gods you know as we find things
depicted and say the Fatal or the
phaedris
there won't be any any anger among them
um because they are all like you know
inhabiting this wonderful uh existence
outside of the body and you know there
they are seeing the forms they're also
like engaging with each other
um so you know they um
that little Commonwealth of gods and
human beings that would be lacking anger
but in human affairs
you know we're going to have anger
arising and it's it's not just through a
lack of knowledge there's all sorts of
other things as we're going to see as we
move on to the Republic there's a part
of ourself that gets riled up right and
we actually we need that part in order
to get things done according to to Plato
all right Mark says I know this wasn't
in the reading list but in preparing for
this session
I was thinking of the discussion in the
youth edemas and how the display of
aristics eventually devolves into the
brothers insulting the other's fathers
it seems they believe victory in
dialogue requires inciting anger in
their interlocutor and banking on that
anger derailing their logic yeah I'd say
that that's that's fair and
interestingly when we get to Aristotle
later on he mentions in unsophistical
refutations if I remember right that
sort of strategy of like getting your
interlocutor ticked off so then they say
stupid things right they they forget
their their train of thought right
um so I think yeah there's something to
that I think as well there's a kind of
social status or capital or whatever you
want to call it that comes with pointing
out that the other person is angry and
you know we're like well you're or
losing it bro you know why so angry and
it's it's implied that if somebody is
getting angry then it's because they're
losing the argument right and that might
not be the case at all I mean somebody
might get angry because they put forward
a good position well argued and the
jackasses that are supposed to be
listening to it
um are just acting like jerks acting
like trolls right I think a lot of
trolls do that that sort of thing and I
think that we could see the sum of not
not all of but some of the
um sophists as being kind of like trolls
you know
um
again not not all of them from from
ancient times but yeah so Mark says the
you mad meme
so I think I think there's something
definitely there June says is Socrates
bringing out frustrations that
ultimately result in anger so that's
that's an interesting
question
um and I would say yes but I want to
explain I want to unpack that a little
bit
so we can get angry for a lot of
different reasons right
anger is not a very simple emotion
and if we're already frustrated in
trying to understand
a complicated topic and we're not making
as much progress as we'd like so we're
we're conscious of our own lack of full
knowledge about something right
and then somebody else comes along and
seems to be you know like poking at us
or making fun of us or being ironic as
Socrates is oh you're so smart why don't
you tell me all about this thing and
we're like well all right here's my
theory and then Socrates knocks it down
uh you know that could you're already
frustrated right and now that
frustration can move right into and fuel
anger against the target the person
who's actually calling you out and
making you look foolish or stupid right
so I think that can that can sometimes
be what's going on and
if you think about Socrates trial right
there's a lot of frustration in Athens
yeah okay June says like hitting a raw
nerve that that's a great example so in
Athens they have gone through years and
years of warfare ups and downs you know
some catastrophes this guy's Socrates
has been associated with people who um
like alcibiotes in particular who really
played a role in screwing things up so
you know a lot of people were probably
like yeah that
that guy's got it coming you know and
now he comes into the court and he he
says I'm not going to be like the rest
of you Schmucks and you know have my
kids cry or make an argument like this
I'm just going to tell it to you as it
is and by the way you should give me
free meals for Life instead of punishing
me
um they're ready to discharge some of
that anger frustration perhaps even
hatred against him right so I think
there's there's really something there
and I we could generalize this and when
we're talking about these Dynamics the
dynamic from the Youth of fro
disagreeing about moral qualities and
their applications the dynamic from the
gorgeous about you know trying to
understand difficult topics and thinking
that you're interlocutor is trying just
to win not to actually or score points
as we say not to actually like engage in
real dialogue with you
and the claims that people make in is
protagoras said to expertise they don't
really have
I think we're ready to be angry with
them and so that that's actually a
a good point I mean I also think that
Socrates manages to produce some new
anger as well on the part of uh people
um that he's involved with and and some
people like forsimichus are already
pissed off just walking into the room
and Socrates turns out to be able as we
find out later on in the Republic to get
him to calm down or maybe through
simicus exercise some self-constraint so
any other uh questions these are some
some good ones so far
so Jamie says in the Youth of fro
there's talk of impious actions leading
to pollution am I correct in thinking
this pollution as the gods becoming
angry at that humans I mean I wouldn't
read that in because it doesn't actually
say it there
um the gods could just be disgusted with
pollution the gods could be worried
about it it's I don't think there's a
reason to just read one particular
emotion into that
um and the the concern that euthyphro
has he's kind of a fastidious guy when
it comes to that you know
um
perhaps more so than the the rest of the
Athenians he thinks he knows all about
you know the gods too
all right so Mark says
um sorry if this was discussed earlier
how do you understand the connection
between anger and the thumos Plato
doesn't seem to have a notion of
righteous anger but if the thermos has a
defensive role as linked to the
Guardians would anger be a healthy
emotion in relation to that
psychological faculty the example I like
to think of is a mother who gets angry
at seeing her child being hurt responds
to in a spirited manner in their defense
yeah totally I mean Plato thinks that
um so the thumos is the part of us that
gets angry it's how it's described in uh
Republic book four so it does other
things as well it's not just getting
angry it's also desirous of Honor it's
the energy that we need in order to do
things but anger is a big part of it's
also the part that you know can be
developed into courage or where
defective cowardice can can happen
um I wouldn't say that Plato doesn't
have a notion of righteous anger it's
just not articulated as such you know
um
you know the thumos that is directed
against enemies in the Republic as we're
going to talk about next session
um that would be easily to describe his
righteous anger I mean we do have to be
careful anger does have to remain within
uh constraints that rationality is
giving it that the higher part of
ourselves right
but
um
Plato doesn't think that anger is
you know automatically bad the way that
some later thinkers will and he thinks
that it has uh when guided correctly
um it has its proper roles so yeah
that's something we'll talk much more
about in the uh the next session
a lot of the Dynamics that we're looking
at here
um anger is not particularly productive
you know getting angry at people because
they view the good the the Beautiful the
just differently than you do
doesn't seem to be particularly helpful
um getting angry at interlocutors that
you think aren't arguing in good faith
and are just trying to win
I mean if it leads you to doing
something like saying well this this
jackass we're not going to have any
productive conversation block right
then I think Plato would be cool with
that I don't think he would say that you
want to become a blockaholic you know
and indulge that all the time anytime
somebody crosses me I block him I don't
think he'd go for that but
um
you know Plato's not a stoic right uh
anger can and does when properly
developed and guided and directed serve
useful roles
in in our lives he thinks and within our
society so you know we do need Guardians
um to to uh engage in that but there's
always the danger of them
you know going astray
um and again we'll talk about that more
in the the next session
any other questions comments people have
oh from Mark do all the fake quotes on
Facebook make you angry not just
Facebook Twitter LinkedIn you know
there's whole YouTube videos full of
fake Quotes no they don't make me angry
um
I you know I think that it's unfortunate
that
um
people who are you know like trying to
make a buck or establish themselves you
know get get some social clout are
um circulating around quotes that if
they knew anything about the the author
they'd be like well that doesn't sound
like Aristotle at all that doesn't sound
like Plato at all they wouldn't say that
sort of crap you know
um
but you know I think
we're now at the point where there's so
much of that that stuff out there
um
then it's going to be we're never gonna
like put an end to it right so I I do
videos and I call out people when they
engage in fake quotes in part because I
think truth matters you know what I do
get upset with are the people who are
like well it's still a true statement
even if they didn't say it or how did
you know they didn't say it and I'm like
you dumbass I mean you just showed that
you don't care about the truth at all
because you're perfectly willing to
falsely attribute something to a famous
author so that people will think that
you're smart or important or something
like that
um I mean these are signs that somebody
is to use the the gorgeous stuff not not
you know working in good faith they're
not interested in truth they're
interested in something else like being
the big shot this Philo Nikia right
um and so then you know if people have
responses like that I usually just block
them you know because there's not going
to be any productive conversation with
them from that point on and I've made
the point that I wanted to make that it
was a fake quote and uh other people can
um decide what they want to do with that
you know
so I mean we should ask ourselves if
we're going to think in these platonic
terms and not like say more extreme
positions on anger like that of you know
the stoics or some of the early
Christians like John Cassian
what's worth getting angry about
somebody being wrong on the internet
that's probably not worth being angry
about right because as Seneca points out
in on anger if you're going to get angry
about one thing and you're just you
should get just as angry about the next
thing and you're the wise person will be
angry all the time then because people
are saying and doing stupid things all
the time right Plato would probably uh
you know
be willing to say you can get like
irritated that's that's the most
um but maybe don't get so angry at
people where you're out of control and
you're like you know hammering away on
the keyboard I can't believe you SOB or
something like that
uh June says uh anger the emotion anger
stems from thoughts yeah it stumps from
thoughts but not just thoughts alone it
has a root in our our psychology and in
our body even and it's something that's
interpersonal and you know we learn
through culture and all that sort of
stuff so thought plays an important role
in it and this is something too that I
think is is quite important
um
so a lot of people view the emotions as
like not involving thought as being what
we call non-cognitive and that's
clearly not right you know and and the
ancient philosophers
um
thought that we do have a lot of
cognitive
aspects and components to the emotions
we feel whether it's anger or fear or
Joy it's not just like something that
happens to us and we we don't have any
ideas going on right
um so there is a cognitive aspect to to
it and that's that's very important and
like June points out it suppose it comes
from your own values and beliefs of
right and wrong
I mean nobody has their own values of
values and beliefs of right and wrong we
we do share them with other people
um and we've gotten them in significant
part from other people but there is
variance like we pointed out with the
euthyphro uh uh Dynamic right even the
gods disagree according to Socrates
about what's right and wrong good and
bad beautiful and ugly
um so that's you know that's that's
quite true
um there's so there's a value component
there's a cognitive component there's an
affective component there's all sorts of
things all coming together in emotions
um I think a lot of people want emotions
to be simpler than they are and that's
kind of a recipe for
getting getting emotions you know other
people wrong and getting you know off
track in your own emotions emotions are
really complicated and it's uh it's good
to recognize that and the to go back to
Plato people like Plato can without
providing us with a complete theory of
this emotion
certainly give us some useful guidance
to make sense of it
well we're getting close to the the end
of the time that I've got allotted uh
Mark says um
a bit of a broad question any thoughts
on how Plato's anger at what happened to
Socrates and Athens at large influence
the writing of his dialogues we don't
know that Plato was angry at what
happened to Socrates
um we we know that he didn't like it but
I haven't seen some you know record that
said Plato was angry at this and
therefore he did this and I I don't
think we know that about xenophon either
who also writes an apology and Symposium
and other uh uh Socratic dialogues as
well or the other dialogue writers that
we know wrote dialogues that we don't
have anymore
um
you know in a way that would be the sort
of thing like Nietzsche would would say
that you know Plato's resentment against
the ill treatment of his teacher led him
to you know like retaliate with
dialogues or something like that
um I don't know that that's the case I
will say too it's quite interesting and
kiss the knees
prosecuted
and if I remember right anatis as well
um but we don't know that he did it out
of anger either
um we know that uh he thought that what
they did was unjust and foolish
but we don't know that that anger was
actually involved there we could we
could maybe read it in if we want to but
that's that's on our part reading it in
right saying well I would be angry uh uh
or people in general would be angry if
their teacher was unjustly executed so
therefore uh you know we're going to
read that into Plato but we don't know
that that's that's actually the case so
well any other questions comments
all right well I'm not seeing any so I'm
going to say uh thanks to everybody for
attending and for the the great
questions and comments
um we'll be picking up Plato again next
session
and
um there we're going to look at the
Republic and the um
Timaeus the phaedris and talk about the
tripartite soul